[Music]
hello dear friends we want to thank you
for tuning in today for our program I'd
like to know uh we really enjoy
receiving your questions and doing the
research to try and find answers we
learn a lot in the process of answering
the questions that you send us of course
there are some questions that we can't
answer because they involve Mysteries
that God has not revealed but if your
question has an answer in the Bible we
do our best to try and find the answer
uh if you want to send us your questions
uh you can do so at the following
address that you'll find on the screen
TVM tv.org once once again TVM tv.org
please be patient we receive many many
questions and uh sometimes we only
answer one or two questions in each
program so they kind of pile up but uh
we will get to your question eventually
and so be patient keep tuning in and
watching our program my name is Steven
bour I'm the president of su TV and
secrets unsealed and I have with me my
good friend Pastor David Salazar uh who
is a regular here on this program uh he
is very much appreciated here for the
work that he does uh particularly for
our Spanish broadcasts but he also does
a lot of English programming and Pastor
it's a pleasure to have you here with us
thank you Pastor Bor it is always an
honored to be with you and to be able to
share this time and this space together
here to study and God willing answer the
questions that our friends have praise
the Lord um we do want to have a word of
prayer before we begin we always pray
pray for the guidance of the holy spirit
because only the Holy Spirit who gave
the Bible is able to explain it to us
today so we can understand it and then
so that we can apply it to our daily
lives so I want to ask you to please
have a word of prayer absolutely let us
pray Heavenly Father we thank you once
again Lord for allowing us to come
before your throne of grace for allowing
us to know your word to study to
understand but as we know and you have
said it is the Holy Spirit the one that
teaches us the truth that lead into all
the knowledge the understanding that is
necessary for our lives and so we humbly
ask that you will grant us the Holy
Spirit today as we open your word as we
answer the questions so that the
questions May uh have the power of your
word uh so they may reach the hearts and
give the right answers to those that are
watching and listening we thank you for
being with us we pray this in Jesus name
amen amen okay last time we had a
question that we kind of rushed through
at the end because we ran out of time
yes so maybe we might want to dwell on
it just a little bit more absolutely uh
as we begin this program it has to do
with um the difference between imputed
righteousness and imparted righteousness
right and uh basically I want to read
the question again does Jesus
continually impute his righteousness to
us to make up for our deficiencies as we
strive through faith in him to render
perfect obedience to God's requirements
and that without the imput of Christ
righteousness to make up for our
deficiencies we should be lost because
the best that we alone can do is bad if
yes what about imparted righteousness
what role does it play in Salvation uh
thanks in advance so uh you know
justification changes our status in the
sight of God but sanctification changes
our lifestyle it changes our life uh so
uh what can we add to this concept of
the difference between justification and
sanctification uh do do we need both in
other words in order to enter the
kingdom absolutely Pastor W I will
answer this way if the Lord declares us
righteous because he loves us and he
forgives our sins he also wants us to
not only be declared but also to abide
with him sanctification is that
experience of abiding in Christ if you
come to the Lord and you confess your
sins and you say Lord I I know I made
all these mistakes I recognize my sins
and you ask the Lord for to forgive you
he'll forgive you but if you decide to
say you know I love your forgiveness I
accept it but let me continue or let me
go back to my sins and let me be away
from your presence and inviting with you
then it really it's a a a curse in a
sense is it's like we're rejecting the
grace of God we're rejecting the
opportunity of God to truly be
transformed and be uh be able to
overcome that experience of sin this is
where John 1 John chapter 3
vers six become very clear it says there
whosoever abided in him sinth not
whosoever sinth had not seen him neither
known him so this is a very interesting
verse because it explains that those
that are in the experience of abiding in
Christ are able to look at sin and not
want to sin to look at the things of the
sin and they say I want to overcome I I
want to have the power of Christ so
abiding in Christ allows us to be able
to have that victory that experience of
growth we're not ever going to be
achieving uh a concept of perfection in
our own eyes but as we walk with Christ
we will be able to have that power to
have overcome to grow and what may seem
at one point in the beginning of our
Lives as something we enjoy we end up
this is liking and hating because God
puts his his heart his love or his
character in US yeah you know uh Ellen
White Once uh wrote and I'm paraphrasing
what she wrote uh that even though we
are not saved by our works we shall not
be saved without them right um and when
I say our works we need to understand
that it's not really our works it's
God's works because the imparted
righteousness of Christ is as much his
righteousness M as is his imputed
righteousness right in other words the
righteousness that flows into our lives
daily to overcome sin that's not even
our righteousness correct it's the
righteousness of Christ absolutely and
the Apostle Paul pointed this out in uh
in a very well-known verse uh in uh the
book I think it's the book of Ephesians
if I'm not wrong uh or is it Galatians
it might be Galatians Chapter
2 um
I guess it's not it's Ephesians I think
Ephesians chapter 2 and vers 8 and nine
where it says for by Grace you have been
saved through faith and that not of
yourselves it is the gift of God not of
Works lest anyone should boast correct
so here Paul is clearly saying that we
were saved by grace through faith amen
but many people stop at verse 9 yes
verse 10 says for we are his
workmanship created in Christ Jesus for
good works which God prepared beforehand
that we should walk in them uh so and by
the way when the Bible uses the word
walk in a figurative sense it has to do
with our conduct right or our Behavior
so God created the good works to produce
those good works in us because we are
his workmanship
so you know we're not saved by works
alone we're not saved by faith alone
we're not saved by faith plus works we
are saved by a faith that works amen
because a faith that does not work is
not really faith in Hebrews chapter 11
everyone is doing something it's a
chapter of Faith right Noah is building
an ark Abel is offering a sacrifice
Abraham is leaving his land uh you know
U Abraham is offering his son so
everybody's doing something because
Faith true Faith amen is demonstrated by
what you do what you do does not save
you but what you do is an evidence that
you are saved and if if you're not doing
it's because you're not being saved
absolutely and this is where living in
abiding in Christ uh as as John says he
that is born of God you know does not
commit sin for his heat remaining in him
when you are in Christ when you are
connected to the source the actions as
you mention Pastor The Works that we'll
do are going to reflect that living
connection with Christ and when we you
know depart and we commit a sin we have
to promptly come back to the Lord and
connect again and to continue that
Growing Experience and I think this is
where the majority of of Christianity
Today modern Christianity is really
missing the blessing as they only
emphasize
justification and they take away the
concept of sanctification from the
experience of of Christian growth and it
really creates
a handicapped Christian if you will
handic religion yeah a frustrating
experience course because you know if
you're always committing the sin over
and over and over again it's a
frustrating experience absolutely we
need to ask the Lord not only for
forgiveness we need to ask the Lord to
give us victory over through the power
of the holy spirit amen that's what God
wants for us you know it's it's uh as
the song goes Rock of Ages yes it says
cleanse me from the power of sin and
cleanse me from the guilt of sin the
double cure absolutely uh is referred to
there in that very famous classic hymn
Rock of Ages okay well let's go to our
next question uh this one comes from
Hastings
Malawi and um the question is this I'm
Hastings B writing from Malawi how can I
manage secular duties without
disregarding any of the Bible
principles it seems more challenging to
be an accountant in any other secular
profession at the same time F fully
adhering to Bible standards so how can a
person who is working in the public
sector in the secular a part you know
not talking about ministers and so on
but people who who work in secular jobs
how can they live without bending their
principles well Pastor you know there is
an interesting story in the Bible we
have the example of a tax collector
actually there were two Tax Collectors
that we know in the story in the Bible
from Christ time one was Matthew Levi
and he or Levi Matthew he was a tax
collector
and they were known Tax Collectors were
actually hated by the Jews because they
were known not only to tax their people
but also to um twist if you will the the
the laws in their favor to overcharge
taxes and to uh become richer by abusing
of their Authority and the power given
by the Roman um Empire so because of
that we know that they were really un
disliked and they were usually involved
in not correct matters of of business
but we know in in Luke 19 verse 8 that
it says there and zakus stood after his
met with Christ and said unto the Lord
behold Lord the half of my goods I give
to the poor and if I have taken anything
from any man by false accusation I
restore him for oldold so this is a man
who had a business at a work an
accounting work was cooking the books if
you will in a way to to make it for his
own benefit but he recognizes that maybe
you know that the way of the Lord is
different and he did not just gave his
job he's not like giving up his job he's
saying you know I'm going to restore I'm
GNA be a fair accountant I'm GNA be a
fair tax collector I'm GNA give all my
half of my riches to the poor and I'm
going to restore those that have done
wrong four times so I believe the Lord
is not against you use having a skill a
business or any type of uh activity it's
how and what you do with that skill what
knowledge how you use it if for example
you're in an environment where you are
working for a company and they're
constantly telling you you got to do
this way you know hide these things you
know if you are in a dishonest activity
you got to quit that job right I mean PR
simple and say Lord this is not what you
want me to do but the actual profession
is not necessarily a bad profession it's
actually a necessary profession good
accounting is important and so I think
it's just if you're in environment where
you can't or you're in a business where
you are not able to contain maintain the
the principles of God you got to move
away you know it's interesting there's
two biblical examples I think that help
answer this question uh the example of
Joseph and the example of Daniel mhm you
know this person who's asking in the
question is talking about working in the
secular SE sector and um uh you know I'm
sure there are circumstances where it
becomes very difficult to be honest but
imagine imagine Joseph yeah away from
his land in a pagan
environment still being faithful to God
right in his administrative duties you
know in Genesis 39 it says now Joseph
had been taken down to Egypt and Piper
an officer of pharaoh captain of the
Guard an Egyptian bought him uh uh
bought him from the ishmaelites who had
taken him down there the Lord was with
Joseph and he was a successful man and
he was in the house of his master the
Egyptian and his master saw that the
Lord was with him and that the Lord made
all he did to prosper in his hand uh so
Joseph found favor in his sight and
served him then he made him uh put him
uh it says it put him over all authority
so it was from the time that he had made
him overseer of his house and all that
he had that the Lord blessed the
Egyptians house for Joseph's sake and
the blessing of the Lord was on all that
he had in the house and the next verse
it says that all Piper worried about was
the meal that was going to going to be
in the table right you know Joseph was
was faithful in a very very difficult
environment faithful to his daily duties
because it's talking about his daily
absolutely however when it came to
principal when Piper's wife made a pass
at Joseph Joseph says no this is where I
do what God says and he was faithful to
God and he ended up in prison I'm sure
that the person is asking this question
has not reached this uh degree of
severity right the same is true of
Daniel you know towards the end of his
life he was 88 years old MH when this
event took place
uh in Daniel chapter 6 uh you know when
he was thrown into the lion's den mhm at
the end of his
ordeal uh he he says something very
interesting about his service to uh the
king it says in verse 22 of Daniel 6 my
God sent his Angel and shut the Lion's
mouths so that they have not hurt me
because I was found innocent before him
because he did give his principle he
continued praying so it says innocent
before him and also oh King I have done
no wrong before you so it is possible to
be faithful in your daily duties Amen in
your secular duties and at the same time
when it comes to principle to draw the
line uh you know this this person
mentions the difficulty of being an
accountant well if your boss tells you
to cook the books
you quit mhm or you or you tell your
boss you say I can't do that because
it's against my principles it's
dishonest and uh you know if the person
is fired so be it but if the person if
if you know the boss says hey you know I
really appreciate your honesty then he
would still keep his job but absolutely
but he needs to obey God Amen rather
than man that's the principle always
keep your focus in your job that you're
going to be honest and faithful to God's
will to God's reveal will revealed will
in his word amen that you know whenever
you go to work every day say this is a
day I'm going to be honest to the Lord
in everything that I say everything that
I do and then ask the Lord in prayer
please Lord I can't do it on my own help
me to be faithful amen and uh and that's
the focus once you have that Focus uh no
matter how difficult the environment
you're going to be able to be faithful
to God Amen I just this quote I think is
important or this concept Pastor as you
just to add what you said I think we
need to bring our experience of knowing
the Lord to everything that we do even
if it's secular if you will as a matter
of fact just to finish with this simple
quote from Spirit prophecy in uh is a
manuscript released 94 it says the
importance of correct bookkeeping is not
half appreciated religion needs to be
brought into this work so just she an
example of bookkeeping kind of connected
to accounting so religion needs to be
brought into anything that we do and
religion doesn't mean that you're going
to come and preach out loud you
sometimes you can do that but it means
the principles of your commitment to the
Lord to be faithful in the Ten
Commandments in the What the Lord Has
said it has to be brought into every
aspect of our lives especially in our
work as people will know whether or not
we believe in the god of heaven or we
believe in the god of the world so right
you know this reminds me of uh several
cases where uh individuals uh were asked
to bake uh wedding cakes for a couple
for a gay couple or transgender couple
and they refused yeah uh and of course
the media you know they got up in arms
they said oh you know this person is
bigoted because they don't bake the cake
but in this case these people have a
secular business but they are living
according to their principles no matter
what the consequences of course then the
Supreme Court uh you know took the side
of the of the people in the bakery that
that refused to do the cake but it's
just an illustration of when you are
when you are in a secular business you
still have to be 100% faithful to God
Amen you cannot be unfaithful amen and
um you know they can call you bigoted uh
you by the way we need to love those
people absolutely the fact that the cake
was not baked for for a transgender or a
gay couple doesn't mean that that the
baker hates those people no you have to
love the people but you can't go along
with uh with something that violates
your religious principles amen that's
right okay the next question is uh and
this one we're going to have to pick up
a little bit on the uh Next program as
well yes uh yeah sometimes we get all
caught up with giving details and
answers to questions that we run short
of time but anyway uh this question
comes from
Ren uh we don't know where Ren lives but
uh this is the question hi pastors many
thanks for your ministry I am richly
blessed by it I am writing in regards to
Acts
4:12 and then he quotes the verse
neither is there salvation in any other
for there is none other name under
Heaven given among men whereby by we
must be saved nobody can be saved
outside the name of Jesus that's the
point and then here's the question my
question is will my friends who are
atheists and Idol worshippers be saved
they are good people and following the
light which they have thanks for
answering this question so um will an
atheist go to heaven will an idolator go
to heaven is uh the summary of a
question well it's a good question
pastor and obviously it's a concern that
he has for his friends let's remember
this uh the name of Jesus specifically
the name of Jesus was given to Christ
when he came to this earth now before he
come into this Earth as as a baby and as
a man and to die for us the name Jesus
itself is not necessarily heard anywhere
in else in the Bible so is not
necessarily the name itself although
it's important absolutely important now
that we understand the story of Christ
but the Old Testament there's thousands
of people who are saved who didn't
necessarily hear them of Christ it's
really more in relationship to the the
the person Christ the Redeemer the sa of
the world the one that gives us
salvation that's what the vers is try to
say that it is Christ that nobody can be
saved outside of the atonement of Christ
outside of his sacrifice of his life now
there are many in the world who have
never heard of Christ as I mentioned
even in the past in in history but many
who have not have access to the
knowledge of the story of Jesus however
if they did not know Christ Romans
chapter 1 verse 19 tells us that there
is manifestations of who God is in
nature and those manifestations are
enough for people to know that there is
a God in heaven and to know that there's
a right way and the Lord has given us
this holy spirit that speaks to us
through our conscience that tells us
what is wrong and what is right and if
we are willing to seek what's right and
wrong no one has an excuse there's no
excuse for somebody that has never heard
of Christ not to be saved uh so in
summary I suppose that the question is
if they have not received the light but
they lived according to the knowledge
they received they should be in heaven
maybe they were not complet understood
the concepts of idolatry or the concepts
of naming a God and maybe that's what
they were atheist in a sense they didn't
understand that but if they were sincere
God will reveal to them even in nature
so they have no excuse but if they
contain or or cleave to their own
concepts of you know of Salvation or or
religion or what life is about sadly
they will not be in heaven because they
rejected that opportunity of
God Only God Can Read their
heart and there's a very important point
point and that is that Christians do not
have a monopoly on the holy spirit amen
the Holy Spirit works with Muslims the
Holy Spirit works with atheists the Holy
Spirit works not only with Christians
but works on the consciences and the
hearts of individuals who are not
Christians now in our next program
because time is running out uh we want
to read the passage from Romans 1 and
also from Romans Chapter 2 and we also
want to uh read a statement from uh
Ellen White's writings in Desire of Ages
where she speaks about um the the least
the the least of these my brethren
there's a fantastic quote in there about
individuals who never knew the name of
Jesus but through the Holy Spirit the
Holy Spirit implanted the principles of
Christ in the heart well thank you so
much for joining us uh this program is
way too short but we hope that you'll
join us next time for this program I'd
like to know God bless you all
[Music]